- Teachers can play a
tremendously powerful role
in creating a growth mindset culture.
And there are a variety
of different strategies,
and approaches they can use to do that.
One way the teachers can powerfully
role model a growth mindset,
is to really have a
growth mindset about each
one of their students.
To really authentically believe
and communicate to their
students that they
expect each and every one
of them to be successful.
That they believe that
with the right strategies
and with the right effort,
each one of their students can
be successful in their class.
And reach really high levels.
Just as important as
communicating that idea,
is a teacher to communicate
the idea that they're there to
support them in that process.
Not that I believe you can
do this, and good luck.
But rather I'm here to help you.
I'm here to help coach you,
and to help you really learn how
to grow and be successful in my class.
I think another strategy
that teachers can use to
create a growth mindset culture,
Is to focus on the process of learning.
To focus not on the
outcomes, not on the grades
that students get but rather on the
process of growing, and
what strategies they
can use to improve their work.
But it can be really helpful
and encouraging for them,
they can build their
sense of self advocacy.
And help them see that
they are in fact growing
even if they are not
getting the best grade.
If their teacher really calls out the
specific things they are doing well.
Now that can be challenging and
time consuming for teachers.
That means really reviewing
the work that students are doing.
To be able to recognize and
call out those good strategies.
But it can really pay off because it
directs students attention
to making sure that they're
using those good strategies
and help them see
success and whatever that discipline is.
Whether it's math, or
science, or literature as
a combination of learning and mastering
these different strategies.
And they can see themselves
growing and being acknowledged
for being successful in those
many steps along the way
to becoming really great at that subject.
I think another really
important way that the teachers
can role model growth mindset,
is through the way they
talk about themselves,
about their own learning journey,
and the way they approach mistakes.
Creating an environment in which mistakes
are celebrated is really powerful.
An environment in which
students don't have to
worry about making mistakes
because they understand
that their teacher
won't look down on them.
That in contrast those mistakes,
if they pay attention to them,
are like important hints as to what
they can do to ultimately improve.
Some teachers will actually make a
point to make mistakes themselves.
They'll kind of inject mistakes
into their own teaching.
In order for their students
to really be on the lookout
for mistakes and then so
they can model how you should
react when you do make a mistake.
So for example, when their
students catch them making
a mistake the teacher
isn't defensive at all in
the face of that mistake.
They don't try to sweep it under the rug.
Instead they might say thank you,
you know thank you so much
for fixing my mistake.
Let's think about why I made this mistake,
let's think about what strategy I can use
to prevent myself from
making that mistake again.
And in that way the teacher
is kind of modeling,
their providing the kind
of mental scaffolding
that students ultimately
need to engage in themselves.
That way when they make
their own mistakes,
they'll understand what's a healthy
way to react to that mistake.